[Music]
is a vegan diet the most minimalist diet
or is it paleo keto or something else
now max you shared an article recently
talking about the vegan junk meat yeah
uh let's talk about that because i think
we have this accidental understanding of
veganism that's being propagated
throughout our culture that anything
vegan is essentially healthy there are
healthy versions healthier versions of a
vegan diet and we can talk about whether
or not they
provide all of the adequate nutrients
but we had our friend rich roll on the
podcast four or five times by now and so
and he's a paragon of health so there's
a healthy way to do this plant-based
thing but just because something is
vegan has it on the the package that's a
way that they're promoting a product
doesn't mean that it's inherently
healthy right yeah i mean i i don't
think that the vegan diet is optimal i
think it's uh
it makes no sense from an evolutionary
standpoint it's not a biologically
appropriate diet
and there's really no good data to show
that a vegan diet is in any way superior
to an omnivorous diet a diet that
includes animal products
um so no i don't think a vegan diet
is is optimal you know there was a study
that i just shared just came out great
paper published uh
the first author is at i believe
university of adelaide or adelaide
university in australia
and um
in this paper there's this so there's
this
misconception this narrative that
uh when you look at the world's oldest
lived populations which has been coined
the blue zones right of the world yeah
that they're somehow low protein diets
that they that they don't eat a lot of
animal products right first of all the
blue zones have been invented by a
journalist named dan buttner and it's
this pop this this group of seven or
eight different communities right
and
it's just this like story that's been
created right yeah we can look at the
seventh-day adventists right they're
vegetarians they live a long time so it
must be the fact that they're
vegetarians right but they also
their religion their religion um
mandates essentially that they don't
drink alcohol
they exercise regularly they've got very
tight-knit social circles
um
so
it's not it's not the vegetarianism that
that is
leading to their to the to the health
outcomes that we see
and we can pick apart any of these
so-called blue zones in the same way so
this paper this university of adelaide
paper
was like
where does this like story that we're
telling ourselves come from that somehow
meat is associated the meat abstention
is associated with longevity what they
did was they took 175 countries for
which data was available on meat
consumption
on gdp on education levels and on life
expectancy okay because you could argue
that a wealthier country is going to eat
more meat people with higher levels of
education they're going to eat more meat
they control for all those variables and
they found that unequivocally
that
per capita meat consumption was
associated with greater longevity
that in countries where more meat is
consumed people live the longest after
controlling for gdp after controlling
for education levels interesting that's
a correlational study there's there are
no randomized controlled trials to show
that meat is in in any way unhealthy
causes cancer cardiovascular disease or
anything like that yeah the problem with
with meat this is i know as a tangent um
we've sort of left the topic of the
question but
what's so what makes nutrition science
so difficult and yet it makes it so easy
to exploit the ignorance of the american
people and make bogus nutritional
recommendations is this concept of
healthy user bias when you look at the
population level people who consume more
whole grains have better health right
your average american isn't consuming
any whole grains your average american
is consuming
refined grains maximally refined grains
right yeah if you look at the population
level and you were just and you were to
tease out all the people in the united
states
who eat on a regular basis quinoa right
this high flute and grain that most
people don't even know how to pronounce
you take all the people who eat quinoa
chances are those people are also taking
multivitamins on a regular basis they're
exercising more they're more health
conscious
so that's the healthy user bias are they
healthy because of the quinoa or in
spite of the quinoa or maybe the quinoa
is having no effect whatsoever right
with meat you have the inverse effect
right at the population level people who
eat more meat
are more likely to be sedentary they're
more likely to smoke they're more likely
to eat fast food right yeah this is true
for all kinds of meat but it's certainly
true for processed meat right because
what is a processed meat what is
processed meat it's a hot dog
it's the it's the
the thin strips of meat that you get on
a subway sandwich
right yeah that you're eating the chips
and the and the large soft drink with
yeah so
so
and yet
these are the kinds of studies that are
used to make nutritional recommendations
and are used to write
click-bait headlines and are used
especially cleverly by the vegan
community hmm
right yeah
so that was a little rant
and this isn't a knock against the vegan
community no it's not you want to be
vegan by all means yeah right but it's
the it's the health science claims that
they make that are
by and large
for the most part with few exceptions
erroneous and what about the other side
of that though someone like laney who's
asking this question about a vegan diet
maybe she's doing it because
for moral reasons yeah she's decided to
abstain from meat and the other thing
that i hear often the other side of the
story i hate that there are sides here
because you what you're talking about is
you're not talking you're talking about
not choosing a side it's not carnivore
versus vegan yeah right you're you like
all of human history are an omnivore
yeah you look at the hanzo they're
omnivores all you look at the messiah
they're omnivores you look at any
hunter-gatherer tribe that we have
remains of from the past they are
omnivores now it may vary depending on
seasonality on availability of food but
then also
we live in a modern society now where we
also want to be conscious of the
suffering that we're inflicting or and
so uh i think one of the reasons that
that people are so turned off by meat is
the the factory farming and
the
terrible conditions that a lot of
animals are in when they are being
factory farms yes
[Music]
that's true and factory farms are
terrible and you might choose to opt out
entirely
but
by opting out of meat consumption
entirely that's not
i would argue
how you change the system
you use your money to vote for producers
who care
and who are trying to change the system
from the inside yeah you don't just opt
out because in in so doing you're also
compromising i i think your own your own
health right because i do think that
omnivory is is more optimal than
um
than veganism but it's also really
important to note
and
and i i think we can't um
there's this concept of like the ostrich
effect right like where like we we don't
like to hear facts that don't support
our our our pre-existing beliefs but
plant agriculture
still
costs animal lives yeah to the tune of
over seven it's been estimated over
seven billion
animal lives lost per year due to plant
agriculture alone yeah seven billion
with a b with a b wow yeah it's funny to
me that when people who
who think about
you know factory farming is one thing
yeah but then there's also like just the
regular
if you've been to a farm before ryan and
i grew up in the midwest we've been to a
lot i had an uncle who owned a farm i
would spend time there and the amount of
animals that accidentally get killed on
a soybean farm or a coin or a corn farm
yeah is tremendous i mean there's so
many carcasses and so much blood and
and they're being chopped up by all
these machines and even baby deers and
things like that that are being killed
regularly now the intention might not be
there but the death still ends up being
there yeah chemical runoff entering
streams killing fish harming birds have
we somehow just decided that
the life of a single cow is worth more
than all of all of these critters that
are being decapitated
by the by the tilling of land
so
what what i try to argue is
i think that the the one
best reason to not eat meat is that you
don't like it that's that's the most
valid reason
because if you're partaking in any
aspect of
modern life if you're shopping in a
modern supermarket if you're buying your
greens in the plastic container that's
been triple washed if you're
if you're if you're a modern human
you've you've unfortunately got some
quantity of blood on your hands yes yeah
100 which is a it's it's screwed up but
that's why to me it's like that the
ethical argument even the ethical
argument is not is not
well thought out you know if you're
avoiding meat because you don't want to
be responsible for the deaths of any
animals but you're shopping in a modern
supermarket and you're eating ultra
processed
plant foods you're still involved
unfortunately you're complicit in
in the the exploitation the torture the
deaths
of animals it's it's sad but it's it's
true and so
i think that
how do we so the question then should be
how do we minimize
right minimize the area under the curve
of suffering right did you enjoy this
standalone patreon highlight if so you
can listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
slash the minimalists or click the link
in the description your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel 100
percent advertisement free